I want to go back brokers like we were
just having this discussion about the
roots and I'm like a first time I ever
saw the roots I was probably 13 and this
was like 2002 or some [ __ ] okay and this
was after you would probably be stopped
working with him like on a more
production but I remember like buying
the bootleg of organics which was like
the first roots album but it wasn't like
the first major album no yeah that was
do you want more do you want more was
their official debut did organics we
recorded the whole album one day Wow
yeah I'm saying we've recorded the whole
album in one day was that out of
necessity because back then studio time
was expensive in it well yeah but then
at the same time yeah we wanted to you
know make it economical at a limited
budget but we're we're a live band we
were used to playing these songs live
and we were able to all set up at the
same time record to a click or a cowbell
or whatever we were recording right and
the band would start the song and we
would cut them off like they're from the
beginning the end I'm curious totally
different like back then like being
around that early 90s Philly hip hop
energy like especially the roots like
did you feel because at the time there
was no precedent for that much live
instrumentation in hip hop or let alone
a band in hip hop yeah what was did it
feel like as special as like now we
obviously the roots are you know one of
the greatest rap groups of all time back
then as a kid did you realize like what
you are a part of yeah no I mean I knew
we were on some special you know like
there was a couple of things that sort
of resembled what we were doing at that
time but it wasn't what we were doing
like I mean like the diggable plan it
yeah of course and things like what but
they were rapping over samples there was
another group in Philly called the goats
at the time but that was like a college
band but it was like hip-hop like you
know right the roots were special you
know I knew it was gonna have a long
lifespan but I just as much as I loved
being part of it I wanted so much more
to be a record producer and stay in the
studio I'm the kind of person that likes
to like wake up in my house every day
and I'm not a big fan of going on the
road and just chose a different life
yeah so obviously you win your first
Grammy with the roots which was I mean I
love by the way shots everybody watched
your purses battle Oh where's that [ __ ]
was legendary it was it was it was it
got ugly as all I'm saying but like at
what point in time after you pivoted
away from working with them full-time
like what was that that first big look
for Scott Storch as Scott Storch to
brand like as as a solo guy who decided
to break away from this roots crew like
what was that first thing that happened
were you're like oh [ __ ] like I think
this can actually work like I like me as
a record producer can actually be a
thing I went with this dude the guy that
actually got the record deal for the
roots Garret Jackson you know he brought
it to Wendy Goldstein and etc etc but
you know after I left I ended up getting
in contact with this guy and he was took
me to New York from Philly
and we did a run all the way around the
city and went from label to label this
that the other couple of you know I was
hoping that just cut a record while I
was in New York like that's all I wanted
right and sure one guy came to it for me
my first client who was it Busta Rhymes
busting and we made a song called blood
ow
okay and we went on the air strikes huh
it was an anarchy anarchy yeah anarchy
oh and then I set up a gig to come back
the following week and work with Capone
annoy Vega CNN yeah and Capone the day
that I was going to the studio to meet
he literally was getting brought from
prison to the studio so this was like
his first
stop after gain now yeah did you end up
on did you end up havin production on
more report or any or what did you yeah
that's crazy man so